the winner grant schema is a test
designed to stretch computer language
processing to its limit if a machine can
determine an intended referent in a
sentence based only on clues from
context then the machine is using
reasoning to pass the language and
perhaps it should be called intelligent
humans are pretty good at working out
reference based on the context for
example the trophy would not fit in the
brown suitcase because it was too big
what was too big
linguist will sometimes denote reference
in text by using subscript numbers or
letters so if you want to solve that X
and work out what it refers to in that
sentence then you have to know that a
suitcase usually contains things and
that a trophy usually doesn't contain
things and you have to know how
containers work that larger things can't
fit inside smaller things it seems
simple to us because we understand not
only how syntax works and whether a
sentence is grammatically valid but also
because we've got experience of
suitcases and trophies and reality
itself solving that X requires
comprehension Terry Winograd started
this line of thinking in 1972 by
proposing sentences that required that
sort of context the city councilmen
refused the demonstrators a permit
because they feared violence or because
they advocated revolution it was the
scientists that weren't many council
women and there was a lot of revolution
when I grad argued solving that sentence
requires knowing not only who can issue
permits or what a demonstrator is but
also the political interests of a
council the ways in which they view
political change that referent changes
based purely on the context and the
meaning of those last two words now
there are plenty of sentences why the X
is ambiguous where even humans don't
have enough context to work out which
pronoun refers to which person if you're
writing a gay romance story and both of
your main characters use the same
pronouns and appear all the time in the
same sentences then it's going to get
confusing fast in more amateur work like
slash fiction inexperienced writers
often try to clear that up with
synecdoche in place of pronouns but
that's awkward
more experienced writers tend to use
context and careful sentence
construction and leaders never notice it
but Winograd schemers
are designed to be unambiguous for
humans to the point where we wouldn't
even have to think about it but
difficult for computers natural language
processing the ability to understand
language is in huge demand right now
it's what powers Siri and Alexa and the
Google assistant so many companies are
trying to create code that can
understand human requests and let's be
honest hooks to that code sucks right
now
they often just rely on collections of
sentences each word tagged with it's
part of speech they just pick up on key
words like core or how much is and then
extract what they hope are the right
bits around them that doesn't work for a
Winograd schema a team of researchers of
the computer science department of new
york university have assembled a list of
a hundred and fifty of them as a test so
I spread the cloth on the table in order
to protect it
to protect watch obvious if you
understand what a cloth and a table are
and why you might spread a cloth on the
table but if those are just tagged as
nouns with no context and that's
completely ambiguous hi future Tom here
just interrupting to say that after this
video was finished and done and all the
graphics were completed I found out that
someone published a new version of GPT -
which is the leading machine learning
text generation system and I think if I
didn't address that here a lot of people
in the comments will be on what about
machine learning what about AI so I got
a version of GPT - it's set up kind of
like a Dungeons & Dragons adventure
system I told it to create a suitcase
and a trophy and to put the suitcase in
the trophy to see what would happen the
moment you think about it you know what
to do so you do it with your eyes closed
you place your hand on top of it then
with your other hand you take off your
gun from inside your jacket pocket take
aim at it pull back one inch yeah if you
think machine learning is gonna save us
not yet and of course sometimes words
can switch parts of speech main is
usually an adjective but in video games
can be a verb or a noun
humans who've not heard that use before
won't understand it the solution for now
except that series not gonna be grated
complicated questions and hire a team of
underpaid contract workers to manually
tag data in order to help programs learn
patterns but those methods will continue
to fall short because computers are
missing the breadth of knowledge that
humans have access to at least for now
artificial language processing remains
ten years
why just as it has for the last few
decades one of my co-authors Gretchen
McCulloch has a wonderful podcast called
length I Azzam you can listen to it at
the link in the description